in Morgantown West Virginia hi Katherine
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thanks for taking her call sure was um
we have five kids and we are kind of
overwhelmed financially my husband and I
we have a mortgage that's kind of new to
us we've been in for about two years we
have two cars and we have a lot of
health care expenses so we've we've just
kind of got to the point to where we are
exhausted financially and we don't know
how to make more room in our budget to
start eliminating more debts we've been
trying to follow your every dollar app
so we're just kind of we're at our
plateau we feel we feel really
overwhelmed at this point to be able to
provide our a different lifestyle for
our children debt free for ourselves as
well so what is your household income
about one hundred forty five thousand a
year
how much is your house payment about
1,800 a month and how much do you own
your cars between the both of them were
around forty thousand okay which one's
the expensive one we have a van 30,000
were upside down on it they're about
three thefts about $3,000 mm-hmm okay
and when you do your every dollar budget
with a hundred and forty five thousand
dollar income and we've got two car
payments and $1,800 going out for a
house payment where is the rest of this
money going well we have like I said we
have a lot of health care expenses I'm
going all-in going we have a lot of
children that's in therapy every month
and then we we also tied to our church
so
that's we put 10% toward our tithe so
that's that's quite a bit mine off the
top and then just our typical like
utilities perhaps a lot of that cost we
have about a $800 how much is the
therapy running we paid out $600 a month
because we've kind of got everything set
up on payments 12 one-time $600
no between the five children is I'm
sorry each individually no combined and
what is the nature of the therapy
physical therapy physical occupational
speech yes we have one special needs
child that requires a lot when I take
1,800 and 600 and a tithe and I take two
car payments and I buy some food I still
think you're not doing your budget right
well we we budget about a thousand
dollars a month for food feed seven
people for entire month and that
includes
[Music]
what is your take home pay about nine
after taxes and you have anything going
into 401 K we did we were not eligible
until later this year because of a new
employment so you don't know we don't
currently that's correct
so
I don't know where the money's going
still okay I got $9,000
I got an $1,800 how much are your car
payments the two of them together is 800
sorry
so that's 2600 in car and house 3200
with the therapies 4200 with the
groceries
and I'm still not have still got $5,000
left
well we a thousand for Tydings
$4,000 left okay then we have our
housing expenses that includes our water
our gas it cost us approximately seven
to eight hundred dollars a month -
between electric and propane because of
where we live so and then with our phone
and Internet so in our housing well I
think where you are is this I I think
you guys gonna have to live live on the
actual budget that we're writing out and
I think you're gonna find some room
there and I think you're selling the
$30,000 van 800 dollars are caught in
car payments isn't what's known as
insanity when you call me up on a
national radio program and say I can't
make my budget making 145 thousand
dollars a year so that means the Vans
gone and if that doesn't work then we're
gonna sell the house but you guys don't
have to get this balanced you're not in
Congress